every single one of us will lose or has
already lost something we rely on every
single day I am of course talking about
our keys just kidding what I actually
want to talk about is one of our most
important senses vision every single day
we each lose a little bit of our ability
to refocus our eyes until we can't
refocus at all we call this condition
presbyopia and it affects 2 billion
people worldwide that's right I said
billion if you haven't heard of
presbyopia and you're wondering where
are these two billion people here's a
hint before I get into the details it's
the reason why people wear reading
glasses or bifocal lenses I'll get
started by describing the loss and
refocusing ability leading up to
presbyopia as a newborn you would've
been able to focus as close as six and a
half centimeters if you wish to by your
mid-20s you have about half of that
focusing power left 10 centimeters or so
but close enough that you never noticed
the difference by your late 40s though
the closest you can focus is about 25
centimeters maybe even farther losses
and focusing ability beyond this point
start affecting near vision tasks like
reading and by the time you reach age 60
nothing within a meter radius of you is
clear right now some of you are probably
thinking that sounds bad but he means
you in a figurative sense only for the
people that actually end up with
presbyopia but no when I say you I
literally mean that every single one of
you will someday be presby Opik if you
aren't already that sounds a bit
troubling I want to remind you that
presbyopia has been with us for all of
human history and we've done a lot of
different things to try and fix it so to
start let's imagine that you're sitting
at a desk greeting if you were press v
op ik it might look a little something
like this
anything close by like the magazine will
be blurry
moving on to solutions first reading
glasses these have lenses with a single
focal power tuned so that near objects
come into focus
but far objects necessarily go out of
focus you have to constantly switch back
and forth between wearing and not
wearing them to solve this problem
Benjamin Franklin invent
what he called double spectacles today
we call those bifocals and what they let
him do was see far when he looked up and
see mirror when he looked down today we
also have progressive lenses which get
rid of the line by smoothly varying the
focal power from top to bottom the
downside to both of these is that you
lose field of vision at any given
distance because it gets split up from
top to bottom like this to see why
that's a problem
imagine that you're climbing down a
ladder or stairs you look down to get
your footing but it's blurry why would
it be blurry
well you look down and that's the near
part of the lens but the next step was
past arm's reach which for your eyes
counts as far the next solution I want
to point out is a little less common but
comes up law in contact lenses or lasik
surgeries and it's called mono vision it
works by setting up the dominant eye to
focus far and the other eye to focus
near your brain does the work of
intelligently putting together the
sharpest parts from each eyes view but
the do is sees slightly different things
and that makes it harder to judge
distances by knock you lately so where
does that all leave us it seems like
we've come up with a lot of different
solutions but none of them quite restore
natural refocusing none of them let you
just look at something and expect it to
be in focus but why well to explain that
we'll want to take a look at the anatomy
of the human eye the part of the eye
that allows us to refocus to different
distances is called the crystalline lens
there are muscles surrounding the lens
that can deform it into different shapes
which in turn changes its focusing power
what happens when someone becomes press
biopic it turns out that the crystalline
lens stiffens to the point that it
doesn't really change shape anymore now
thinking back on all the solutions I
listed earlier we can see that they all
have something in common with the others
but not with our eyes and that is that
they're all static it's like the optical
equivalent of a pirate with a peg leg
what is the optical equivalent of a
modern prosthetic leg the last several
decades have seen the creation and rapid
development of what are called focused
tunable lenses there are several
different types mechanically shifted
álvarez lenses deformable liquid lenses
and electronically switch to liquid
crystal lenses now these have their own
trade-offs but what they don't skimp on
is the visual experience full field of
view vision that can be sharp at any
desired distance okay great the lenses
we already need already exist
problem solved right not so fast focus
to number lenses add a bit of complexity
of the equation the lenses don't have
any way of knowing what distance they
should be focused to what we really need
are glasses that when you're looking far
far objects are sharp and when you look
near near objects come into focus
anywhere in your field of view and
without you having to think about it but
I've worked on these last few years at
Stanford is building that exact
intelligence around the lenses are a
prototype borrows technology from
virtual and augmented reality systems to
estimate focusing distance we have an
eye tracker that can tell what direction
or eyes are focused in using two of
these we can directly triangulate your
gaze direction to get a focus estimate
just in case though to increase
reliability we also added a distance
sensor the sensor is a camera that looks
out at the world and reports distances
to objects we can again use your gaze
direction to get a distance estimate for
a second time we then fused those two
distance estimates and update the focus
tunable lens power accordingly
the next step for us was of course to
test our device on actual people so we
recruited about a hundred press B ups
and had them test our device while we
measured their performance well we saw
convinced us right then the autofocus
were the future our participants could
see more clearly they could focus more
quickly and they thought it was an
easier and better focusing experience in
their current correction put it simply
when it comes to vision autofocus don't
compromise like static Corrections and
used today do but I don't want to get
ahead of myself there's a lot of work
for my colleagues and me left to do
for example our glasses are a bit bulky
maybe and one reason for this is that we
used bulkier components that are often
intended for research use or industrial
use another is that we need to strap
everything down because current eye
tracking algorithms don't have the
robustness that we need so moving
forward as we move from a research
setting into a startup we plan to make
future autofocus eventually look a
little bit more like normal classes for
this to happen we'll need to
significantly improve the robustness of
our eye tracking solution we'll also
need to incorporate smaller and more
efficient electronics and lenses that
said even with our current prototype
we've shown that today's focus tunable
lens technology is capable of
outperforming traditional forms of
static correction so it's only a matter
of time it's pretty clear that in the
near future instead of worrying about
which pair of glasses to use and when
we'll be able to just focus on the
important things
[Applause]